[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones here
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host
and uh we're glad to have him with us
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five his number one
bestselling book own your past
change your future is still zooming and
zooming and zooming as well as podcasts
so if you want to talk about your life
and your money we're here the call is
free and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it triple eight
eight two five five two two five david's
gonna start us off in amarillo texas hi
david how are you
pretty good dave how are you today
better than i deserve what's up
well
uh
i have recently remarried about three
years ago
and uh was very near debt free and
my
wife after we got wet i told my wife
before we got married we weren't gonna
have any debt and
except the house and so
anyway
uh on our first anniversary i bought her
a
sleep number bed which is very expensive
and i charged it well
now she she likes to spend money like
it's made of water like there's an
endless supply
and
i can't get her to
to sit down with me and
and create a budget
and
and i you know i would really like to do
the financial piece university with her
uh but
i just don't know how to
get her to agree to those things well
the first thing you don't do is say dave
ramsey said
whatever you've already did it didn't
you
yes sir yeah you turned me into a cuss
word man
you you wimp you blamed it on me and the
second thing is you can't tell your wife
okay this going into our my new marriage
this is gonna be a key priority for us
until the first big purchase and then
i'm gonna go ahead and just uh knock
down my own boundary and then get mad at
you for walking through that gate that i
opened up you can't do that
yeah so i understand
what you've got to do is you have to
dial back because both of you engaged in
childish behavior
and we have to both dial back to adult
behavior
adults devise a plan and follow it
children
do what feels good
and so what you're discussing is the
symptom the symptom is overspending the
symptom is debt
the symptom is a sleep number bed you
financed a bed a bad man a bed
you gotta say that out loud
so you have to dial back and go those
are symptoms and the the problem that
caused those symptoms to occur
is
vision lack of it you do not have a
shared vision for your wealth in the
future
and what your wealth will do for you it
will allow us to travel it will allow us
to buy this it will allow us to be
generous in this way and we have to do
things to cause that wealth to happen
and one of those is avoiding debt going
forward and that includes me because i'm
a bonehead and i broke my own word here
you got to start with apologizing deeply
a deep bow and scrape
and uh beg for forgiveness and then say
but the reason i wanted us to do that
even though i screwed it up was because
i believe if we stay out of debt these
are the things that are going to happen
let's talk about why and where we're
going and changing our family tree and
retiring with dignity and being in a
position to be unbelievably generous and
those kinds of big things
then she can get on board and oh by the
way you get a vote and i get a vote we
both have a vote and we don't go against
that my wife and i were discussing a
major purchase this morning before i
left home
and she wasn't happy about it and i'm
really happy about it
and um
but later on but later on it got we got
happy you know and so it worked out but
we weren't go i wasn't going to go
forward with that until we're both
in agreement and it fits into our
overall plan yeah
i think it's important
a gun or a truck could be yeah it could
be it could be um
he sidetracked me um so here's another
thing a conversation you can have after
the vision conversation is being curious
with yourself when you're about to buy
something both you and her
the question i always want to ask myself
for me it's eating for me it is i want
to skip a workout for me it's i'm not
going to check in with my wife on this
i'm just going to go do it
right when i'm about to make a behavior
that i know is going to cost me
downstream
which has been transformative for me is
instead of getting mads of getting
frustrated is stopping and being curious
and asking myself what am i trying to
protect myself from what is this amazon
purchase what am i trying oh i'm bored
oh
i had a a a tiff with my six-year-old
and i'm pouting and so i'm gonna go buy
some more i don't know
fishing line or something stupid that i
don't really need what am i doing this
stuff for and then that's always gonna
push me back to the vision right which
is oh we're doing this for this i'm not
going to hit it for this right i'm not
going to hit purchase i'm not going to
go buy this i'm not going to buy a 9 000
bed on credit
um because we have a different vision
for our life but the the
the most asked question since i started
this show 30 years ago how do i get my
spouse on board yep and number one
answer is don't
say dave ramsey said because nobody
cares what dave ramsey said it's got to
be about us it's got to be from inside
right yeah and no really the truth i
mean that's not me just being humble or
weird or something yeah i mean you know
at the end of the day your opinion for
your life is that you're the only one
gets a vote in your life i imagine if i
don't get a vote in your life if sharon
came to you and said dave
my friend dan says that i should hold
your hand more so i'm gonna start doing
that that wouldn't mean anything right
but if if if my wife comes to me and
says
hey i i want to start holding your hand
i mean like i thought like i want to get
closer to you that means something me
but you always you number one you don't
blame it on me number two
there's a whole get out of that thing
here is so that right what's your so
that yes
it's so that we can be not broke anymore
and stressed it's so that we don't ever
act like
you know we're not we've both talked
about your parents are are pitiful yeah
we're sad about their financial
condition we don't want to be them when
we're old
it's so that we're going to avoid debt
so that we're not them we're going to
avoid that so that we've got a pile of
money we send the kids to college with
any debt we want to
be so that we'd like to open a a
hospital in our neighborhood and drop 10
million dollars into that so that i
don't know what you're so that is but
you need to sew that because debt in and
of itself is not worth it that's right i
mean it's good it's good get out of debt
it's a good thing but the only reason we
want you to get out of that the reason
we teach you get out there it's so that
yeah you get financial peace yes and so
that you can do things yes and you can
say when that kid comes to your door you
don't kind of find nickels of pennies
you can buy all the candy right you can
do those generous things man you can
just completely
buy out all the inventory of the girl
scout wouldn't that be fun that would be
fun just mess with her day and what
would be really great is to have
75 boxes of cookies and i'll try to
explain my wife i'm just doing a good
thing huh buy buy a single mama car yeah
exactly i'll buy 10 on my car exactly
you know i mean change your life man
take that girl in the youth group and
pay for college but the problem is when
we get down into the weeds
it all comes down to a sleep number bed
becomes a math problem instead of a
heart it's a sleep number bed what what
what
yeah i mean
god i wish i could go back and tell you
all the stupid butt stuff
i have done with money and bought things
i have bought that are just hilariously
stupid
sleeping over bed wouldn't be on the
list but i've done some hilariously
stupid things
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author ramsey personalities my co-host
today lisa's with us in chicago hi lisa
how are you
how you doing good how can we help
so i'm in the middle of negotiating my
salary for a new job
and i'm a little bit
don't know how to handle it or how to
take it from here and
to give you a little bit of background
uh i'm in a dead-end i.t job so i
decided to go somewhere else plus get a
certification
so my next job i asked for
i currently make 73 base
i ask for
but they're not willing to pay more than
75.
so
how big a company is this
it's big
big
yes financial uh during the financial
industry okay all right
well you probably got your number you
just need to decide if you want to work
there i doubt that they're going to do a
bunch of negotiating i think they've
told you what they're going to do you
might get a little bit out of this but
uh
the the the way to posture and position
yourself so you don't harm yourself into
a brand new job you don't automatically
end the honeymoon before it starts
um is just switch shoes for a minute
if you were that supervisor that's
interviewing you
or that company that's interviewing you
why would you give you more money i want
it is not a reason
okay and i had a magic number in my head
that they didn't meet doesn't make them
a bad person
i was the worst i would have a magic
number in my head and it was so
sometimes it was ludicrous and then the
boss would come in and i'd feel like
they and offer me hey here's a job
and here's 5 000 less than your magic
number and i would feel that as a loss
like they had taken something from me
right if they had it all right yeah
they'd offered me a job and so you just
have to decide do i want to
change my life for 2 000 bucks and a big
company that if you go in there and bust
it and do great work and provide value
will increase your salary over time in
in different roles and professional and
professional responsibilities right so
the way i would approach it is i would
just ask the hiring supervisor that
you're talking to or whatever the phrase
is that you use
how could i add more value
in this position that would make me more
valuable
that would make you guys want to pay me
more
i don't want you to give me more money
just because i i think i deserve it
because i breathe air i'm willing to do
things that are moral and reasonable
extra
i'm willing to
add
elements to this that that you know that
make me more valuable to this company
and then you'd that that you know what
what would be the thing i would need to
well you need to get this certification
great can we agree that when i get this
certification then i that it comes with
an automatic raise that matches that and
i'll go get the certification and you
can start at the lower position and then
go get the certification six months
later and get your raise right
um or whatever but but you're asking
you're not asking them to give you
something because you're entitled in any
way
no i'm not i don't feel that way at all
i know and so make sure you're
vocalizing it that way
how can i how can i add value
that because i would really like to make
80 but i don't expect you to pay me that
or 85 i don't expect you to pay me that
unless there's a reason
and so i'm asking you
what would i need to do to be worth 85
or 80 or whatever for you guys because
i'd really like to get there help me
because i'm all about personal growth
i'm all about getting better and i'm all
about making sure that i make you more
than i cost you
okay well thank you i appreciate it sure
and i think
dave you that that wisdom is good
because she enters into a conversation
that's with not against and she might
find out oh man we pay this this is a
big company and so we pay this band of
employee x and y and you're at the top
of that range but we're going to move
you so you find out actually they're
capping the value that they can but so
you find out a lot of stuff when it's
we're on the same side but when we're
across the negotiating table then it's
got to be you versus me right
well a negotiation properly done of any
kind
is not put up your dukes that's right
it's not
i'm gonna take from you
so that i get more right it's not a
zero-sum game
uh in other words if she brought in an
extra million dollars in revenue to that
organization would they gladly give her
more money absolutely in a heartbeat
yeah you know
most of them would anyway some of them
are too stupid to do that but most of
them
most companies small large anything and
so it's like we go win together i tell
folks around here if you leave the cave
kill something and drag it home i will
share it with you right you know i'm not
going i'm not greedy i don't but but
also not going to pay you you know and
one guy go well you know you need to pay
me this because i've got all these
degrees and i'm like he had more degrees
than a thermometer i mean it was like
and i'm like dude your race is effective
when you are right you know this is a
small business so at so all negotiations
are how can we get to where we want to
be together if you're buying something
from somebody how do you keep
i once once i sit across table from
somebody my hackles come up yeah how do
you keep from turning it into a
competition yeah well it the problem is
competitive minutes oh yeah if if
my deal becomes not beating him my deal
become my win is when i get the deal
done okay
did i destroy him
not that i got him to take five thousand
dollars less but no we should get the
deal done because
see the if you get into a
one-dimensional thing on a negotiation
where it's just like a
price on uh you're buying a car from
somebody and the price is this and you
go okay
well i'll give you this well i'll take
that
well back and you go you know it's just
back and forth to you and then you go
we'll split the difference or whatever
and you go back and forth with this
verbal ping pong back and balls on your
side and it balls on my side and every
time we get a little bit closer finally
someone goes enough this is it that
you've reached my point you got my
number and you go okay i'm in or i'm not
uh or
uh but if you can make it about
something else yeah you know it's not
just
the price okay for instance i'm used to
you know buy a lot of foreclosures or
buy a lot of real estate and i would
tell people in those days a house has
been sitting on the market for a while
we will close it this afternoon for cash
[Music]
now that matters
yes you lighten their load a little bit
this is just we're done you got money
tonight
to go buy a lobster dinner baby
i mean this is today you've been
screwing around with this house for six
months you're behind on your payments
tonight
and in return what do i get price a good
house yeah yeah i get a how but i get it
i get a good price but but the immediacy
is a different factor than price right
and so you add other factors into the
equation when you're negotiating and in
her case the factor we're adding in is
how can i add value
to where you wish
that i was here you're happy
that i'm here what can i do to be the
best team player you've ever had on the
team yeah you know and and what does it
look like to be as our friend pat
lincione says the ideal team player
andrew is with us andrew is in kansas
city hi andrew how are you i'm good
thank you for taking the cold days sure
what's up
yeah um i'm just wondering
the question i have is should i sell my
house
um
now there's a lot of
things that happen here in the last few
years uh namely
uh when we when
i say we but i
bought the house at the time
um i was married and i bought it with my
wife expecting you know a larger family
um
and whatnot unfortunately in the same
month we bought it yep
she asked me for a divorce and
uh unfortunately uh we couldn't work and
work the marriage out and
so now
why would you not sell it
why would i not sell it uh
i don't want to make
uh
one i don't i don't want to make an
emotional decision based off the house
and i wanted to do it like a smart way
uh secondly um but you wouldn't buy this
house today in your situation
no okay
when was your divorce finalized
uh
uh last year
yeah
i'm sorry andrew yeah your heart your i
can i can hear your heart breaking in
front of me
you're still really hurting and um yeah
and that's kind of clouding and you
don't trust your own judgment you're not
confidence anymore in your own judgment
so i don't think you're making a mistake
selling the house it's just a stupid
house
and it sounds to me like it's uh it's a
part of a future that died
and it's okay to let it go with the
death of that dream with the death of
that marriage and go start fresh
somewhere to be good for you to have a
new space to be in john you think that's
right i'd sell it i put on the market
today yeah i'll be done with it man i'm
sorry for your time
sorry this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsay personality
number one best-selling author host of
the dr john dolone's show
is my co-host today
you can catch that on podcast
and you should
he talks to folks about mental health
every day boundaries crazy relatives
crazy personal stuff
all kinds of mental health things it is
just downright enthralling you need to
check it out it's a lot of fun to listen
to
and john's common sense approach to a
very difficult subject and his
compassion and and his straightforward
advice is all there the dr john deloney
show check it out on ramsay networks or
anywhere you listen to great podcasts
and you'll be able to do that in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage is bill and jess hi guys how
are you good how are you you're great
you're welcome where do you all live
lake orient michigan okay where's that
near
uh auburn hills it's about an hour and
15 minutes north of detroit okay cool
yeah cool around where you are wonderful
welcome to nashville thanks for having
me and here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off paid off 76 000
in 17 months wow good for you and your
range of income during that year and a
half uh we went from 80 to 120 back down
to 80 uh back up to about 140. okay wow
what do y'all do for a living
jess is a stay-at-home mom and i'm a
robotics engineer okay so why all the
gyration what'd you do take a bunch of
jobs drop them off and something else
happen uh more or less yeah um so 80 was
my starting i started a new position
a little bit before we started our debt
free journey
and then jumped up because i was working
80 to 100 hours every week wow yeah as a
field service engineer so i was gone 80
of the time a lot of travel yeah and
that uh that kind of got burned out a
little bit so step back
took a position that i didn't get any
overtime and in december i started my
own business oh
wow yeah working for myself now yeah
that'll work yeah and now we can control
both the income and the hours absolutely
yeah hardest boss you'll ever have yeah
yeah yeah he's a tough he's a tough one
that's right i don't know about that
slave driver
so what kind of debt was the 76 000
so we had a uh an ikea credit card
for kitchen remodel we had cell phones
we had a truck loan
and student loans
okay
so how long you all been married
eight years okay wow just celebrated
eight years so what happened that lit
this thing on fire 17 months ago how'd
you connect up with this ramsey stuff
yeah i'm uh i'm a ramsey baby i i grew
up on listening to you and dr laura all
the time oh my goodness yeah in the car
so a couple of truth tellers i'm telling
you yeah common sense so yeah um the
reason that we got started because we
were just you know sick and tired of
being sick and tired uh we finally we
always had these excuses up to recently
where while i'm in school we're not
making a lot of money you know okay now
we have money but we have debt to pay
off but we still have all these things
that we've wanted over the past you know
five or six years
and you know we
at the end of the month we just we had
more month than we had money so
eventually i was like okay we're making
more money than we ever have what's
going on so we're still broke and we're
still broke yeah yeah so i was looking
for a budgeting app and at the same time
i was looking for a podcast because we
were remodeling our kitchen
and uh i listened to a lot of joe rogan
so i got burned out on that and well
found you i've
listened to you as a kid so i was like
you know i wonder if uh if uncle dave
has a
podcast and sure enough and we also
started using the every dollar budget
app okay yeah to track everything cool
so jesse comes home and he's like i
found this from my childhood
[Laughter]
and i think i'm tired of being broke
what did you say well he's kind of a
zero to 100 kind of guy so i kind of had
to back it down a little bit and we had
a lot of conversations and we just
listened to a lot of the
um testimonies ah we were across the
world for a little bit but yeah
we um
i don't know we we just had to listen
and discuss and really
have to get on the same page first so he
just kind of came in and went da da
we're going on beans and rice and
selling your car
yeah i joined a cult and you are too
and she said i don't think so
i like her this is great did you have a
picture growing up of what that free
living looked like jess it was just all
new to you well my parents were actually
pretty good with money so i feel like
we're just i i kind of grew up like that
too we're just very goal oriented
ever since we met we were that way we
got married we were kind of young and we
just were like we see what we want and
we go and we get it so it wasn't that
far off but it was it would it sounded
like a good idea i wasn't against it but
it took something for all the things all
the things he was interested in all of
it right right but you guys paid off a
lot of money in a short period a year
and a half with three little ones
tell us about that
yeah a lot of travel like i was saying
before so yeah i mean
being a stay-at-home mom with three kids
by yourself for you know a couple weeks
at a time is uh she was a single mom
oh absolutely yeah
definitely yeah
we had just had our middle child when we
decided to do this so we had a newborn
and a kitchen remodel and he was gone
and it's an ikea one try to put those
things together right right we still are
yeah
[Laughter]
you're a robotics engineer and you don't
know how the cabinets go together right
yeah
kitchen looks great kitchen looks great
he did a good job but yeah then we also
we decided to get you know have another
baby again they're 13 months apart so
okay yep that's we had two babies while
being dead off yeah yeah yeah it's been
a wild ride yeah you guys have been yeah
zero to 100 for sure yeah wow well
congratulations thank you
congratulations okay when you look back
on it you say all right what's the key
to getting out of debt
communication definitely and uh
just keep going not only the same page
but the same pace
right right yeah like i've said before
you know i it's better for
both people to go seven out of ten as
opposed to one person going 10 and one
going zero because
it just doesn't work yeah communication
i think looking at the bigger picture
i think that money is just a way to
count score but the things that this
will change along the journey
especially with like our marriage and
with money we were not on the same page
before we thought we were but we just
didn't really talk about it you know
there were some trust things on my side
going on and
um i think
doing this together and seeing that goal
at the end
just it changes everything it's not just
about your bank account and what you owe
yeah yeah way to go you guys that's
exciting y'all are so cool i'm so proud
of you thank you thank you how does it
feel to be free
i feel like it hasn't hit me no i mean
either
you'll get there quick
one question i've got before we go
totally tangential um i don't even know
if that's how you pronounce that are the
robots going to come get us
[Laughter]
is terminator 2 real nice i'm not sure
yet well
that means yes i knew it i knew it
all right don't feed his conspiracy side
please don't i'll let you know though
hey will you holler i'll give you a
heads up sure give us a heads up yeah
let us know put us on the list of people
you put us on the list
good job you guys we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story you guys have
changed your family tree with all these
beautiful youngsters very very well done
thank you copy a total money makeover
for you to give away with someone you've
inspired and of course financial peace
university a 12-month membership to that
with the brand new videos that include
dr john delonie george camel and rachel
cruz and them look at those beautiful
kiddos what are their names and ages
so this is mabel
she's four this is daisy she's a year
and a half
and hattie is seven months ah
yeah you are totally outnumbered brother
that's good congratulations your dog is
female too so
[Laughter]
we're so proud of y'all well done all
right bill and jason mabel and daisy and
hattie lagorian michigan you did it bad
76 thousand dollars paid off in 17
months making 80 to 120 to 80 and now
self-employed at 140. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go
those little kids have no idea the price
their mom and dad paid mom at home with
three tiny little babies in a kitchen
under construction dad gone gone gone
working working working working to get
their family tree changed
powerful that's real adults right there
you pay a price you serve your family
that's right you win
and everybody was serving right
everybody was serving everybody and
those three little girls are not going
to even understand that stress man
they'll never they'll never have it
they'll never have that same feeling
and it's over and uh one thing about
going through that is he'll make sure
they're trained well he's gonna be
making sure they can deal the robot
invasion coming
that's so he can focus his energy on
that which is exciting man
that's why john's here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here
our wealth building live event tour is
completely blowing up blowing out
yesterday we announced we're completely
sold out for our phoenix show on
september 13th
we were able to add a second show in
phoenix and so we'll be there on monday
september the 12th as well
sacramento minneapolis and san antonio
aren't far behind they're all in the 90
percentile on sold out meaning that
there's probably a couple of weeks worth
of supply of tickets still
if you don't get your tickets soon
they're gonna be gone and we're not
adding new nights to those cities
because we can't get venues
so when those are sold out they're just
like gone
so these are hot tickets it's me rachel
cruz george campbell dr john baloney ken
coleman we're all going to be there
we're going to talk about the crazy
things going on in the world
of money and uh what's happening about
building wealth out there and we'll
answer questions we'll have a panel
discussion we're going to be signing
books and taking pictures and all kinds
of stuff so make sure you come out again
phoenix september 12th just added
september 13th so
almost gone minneapolis almost gone
november 1 and 10. november 15 we're
gonna be one a week through the month of
november san antonio antonio's november
15th so tickets or tickets are only 25
you can get a four pack for sixty
dollars bring some of your friends with
you uh it's less than the cost of a dead
gum pizza so ramsay solutions dot com
slash events get your tickets we want to
have you there it's going to be a lot of
fun these things are a blast we at
ramsey love getting out in all the
different communities and hanging out
with you guys and meeting people and
it's just fun for us and it's obviously
fun for you guys each of these events
are 3 000 or so folks and they're just
about all gone so we love appreciate
that thank you very much for that
phoenix uh richard's with us in columbia
south carolina hi richard how are you
doing great dave good afternoon dave and
ken i've been a long time listener since
2012 and i've tried several different
times yesterday was one of those i ran
short of second in line and had eight
percent on my phone and i had to get
back with austin and say i couldn't make
the phone call so i look forward to that
today so i'm glad it worked out
we got rid of ken though that was
yesterday
you have to go to the b team today so
what's up man no no no no
hey yeah i just um my big question is
what is the best way to set a budget a
retired military member
after 24 years
divorced remarried and now i just
sold my house and paid down all my
portions of the debt my wife and i
have a house that we need to pay off and
only a
auto loan everything else
zero credit card debt
and just the home and the auto but just
trying to set up a budget we not only
have that but we are also entrepreneurs
my wife owns a restaurant she owns a
hair braiding shop she we're both real
estate agents
and i'm a life insurance agent we have a
rental event business
you all need something to do
you're bored yeah we need
we're bored i'm i'm
constantly moving so
so all right
the way the way you lay out a budget is
number one when you're married you have
to do it together
you both have a vote and when we're done
we have to be in agreement and when
we're done we have to speak pinky swear
and spit shake that we're going to stick
to
this plan
that we laid out all a budget is is a
spending plan
that's all it is
and so what you're going to do is at the
beginning of each month
you're going to try to figure out as
best as you can for that particular
month what your income's going to be
now you've got a lot of variable incomes
in this deal so it's going to be a
little hard to hit it perfectly but
usually 30 days out you kind of know the
restaurant's going to do this i got this
closing i don't have anything in the
pipeline to close real estate i've got
this or that i normally make x insurance
whatever it is and you put those numbers
down you say okay this is our income for
the month
and then you spend that income
on paper on purpose
before the month begins and agree on it
with your spouse every
one of your dollars of income each month
brand new month brand new list
has an assignment
and we're going to buy food we're going
to pay lights we're going to pay that
house payment that car payment we're
going to pay extra on that car whatever
it is we're going to do with the money
every one of these dollars down through
here we're going to set aside this much
money for electricity we're going to say
this much money for the water bill we're
going to set aside every dollar has a
name an assignment a mission
and then you look at it together and you
go well i don't really think we should
spend that much on that or i think
that's going to cost more than that no
we can't live on 100 worth of food honey
you're gonna have to raise that one and
so the two of you together make the
adjustments but it still equals zero
at the bottom your income
minus these assignments equals exactly
zero now you have planned
your money for the month
and then you stick to that plan
and if you can't stick to that plan you
have to have an emergency budget
committee meeting and the two of you
have to sit down and adjust the plan
mid-month because something's messed up
the first three months you do this you
will suck at it you'll get a little bit
better each month the first month will
be unmitigated disaster usually
but that doesn't mean you give up it
just means you don't know how to do this
yet and you're figuring it out you're
practicing you're learning
then the two of you work together to
build a plan or adjust your plan build a
plan adjust a plan build a plan adjust a
plan and you'll eventually get really
really good at it
i've been doing it for 30 something
years with my wife and it's it's a
second nature i mean we can do it in
you know like less than two minutes it's
not much to it number one we're gonna
make bills that's helpful but uh
that makes it go real fast but yeah so
so we have to have other issues let's
put that
so yeah that's the thing and jump online
richard and get the every dollar app
and uh you did mention you paid off all
your debt but like your wife didn't have
debt or had that or something no that's
not how this works when you're married
whatever debt she has is yours whatever
debt you had is your is hers we
are married and so we
are operating as a team and the people
that win with money operate as a unit as
a couple
not uh not not like roommates
and so get on the same page
we're gonna completely clean this whole
thing up for both of you and then we're
gonna completely build wealth for both
of you the everydollar app is free to
use just jump online and start using it
and you're going to find in this new
marriage
that doing these things together is
going to create a common vision a common
language and your marriage is going to
get better and your parenting is going
to get better and then you can take
these lessons and apply them to all 411
of your businesses and you're going to
see those things tighten up and clean up
too it's awesome man yup good for you
rick is with us in tampa hi rick how are
you
dave
dr john thank you uh for taking my call
i i really needed your insight and uh
uh advice uh an issue that i'm
struggling with emotionally as well uh
here's my situation fellas i'm i'm 64.
i've been retired for seven years now
and divorce as of three years ago
i had never taken a penny out of my
retirement um
until my divorce when of course my
ex-wife was owed some and that was just
you know transfer of funds i live on uh
71 000 a year as comprised of a pension
and social security and i live quite
comfortably on it and i live a fairly
simple life
i am debt free i i don't know any one
anything how much is in this nest egg
then
well
after the dust settled uh three years
ago i have 835 000 yeah
in that in retirement uh i have 51 000
you know non-qualified in brokerage
i keep about 15 000 the local bank here
and
my my present home uh worth about 400
000.
here's my here's my dilemma um
you know i struggle with you know when
am i going to
start to enjoy some of the fruits of my
labor i'm pretty careful of my money
i am careful with it yeah you've done a
great job
yeah well thank you
you're a millionaire man
well you started from nothing you did
great touchdown i want a super muslim i
well thank you you're a millionaire
after a divorce that's that's incredible
yeah well and i did it with some
limitations that i won't get into some
physical limitations but actually
they're there um but what i'm looking to
do when i'm struggling with i i'm
thinking i want to move up in the house
and when i say move up just change
location get a little closer to the
beach how much would you spend
well
in the neighborhood of 700 maybe 650 to
700. okay you'd have a half a million
left over if you sold your house
so if you buy a 600 000 house you sell a
400 house you pull 200 out of 800 or 300
out of 800. you're gonna have a half
million left over
in seven years when you're 70
uh you said you're 64 when you're 71
you'll have a million dollars in cash in
that one account still so yes you should
move up and you should pay cash for it
and you should sell the one you're in
this is the ramsey show
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth and do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships
dr john dolone ramsey personality host
of the dr john doloni show and number
one best-selling author of the book own
your past change your future is my
co-host today
we'll take your questions at triple
eight eight two five five
two two
five stephanie is with us in springfield
missouri hi stephanie how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for talking to
me sure what's up
um my husband and i have been married
almost a year and for five months of
that
we've been
dealing with the health issue i was
diagnosed with non-hodgkin's lymphoma
and
i'm so sorry
well thank you
so we never gotten a good rhythm
together and our new with as far as
finances were concerned i had to stop
working full-time i'm working part-time
and we've been doing fine but i'd like
to get refocused once my chemo is up uh
in september
and we're gonna have a budget meeting
and celebrate and discuss
so my question is how do we start that
and
get back on track and reapproach
finances after we got kind of derailed
right in the beginning
how old are you
31.
so it sounds like the
prognosis
when the chemo is finished in september
is excellent the way you're laying this
out
yes we're very hopeful it'll be carried
in my pet scan will be cancer free okay
and we start the cancer-free journey
then
well why not just whip cancer in the
first year marriage let's just go ahead
and get that one out of the way oh my
goodness kiddo wow well i'm so sorry
what a strain and what a weird thing to
have to go through
in in year one of marriage i mean wow
that's amazing
uh okay um
well to start with let's just talk let's
just say this doing a budget and getting
on a
plan to build wealth is an important
part of the rhythm of your life it is
not even on the same scale as beating
cancer
okay
so i mean like budget two cancer 12
on a scale of one to ten right so
yeah uh you know i i i amazing you're an
amazing young hero uh congratulations
wow
so uh uh i want you to finish using all
the energy that you have at this moment
to live in the present and knock this
out i know you need to look past the
chemo just to get through it i don't
blame you for that uh but the but but
let's just number one let's just say it
is very very important that it's more
important that you complete this and
that you beat the cancer by far
than it is that you do a budget in
september okay
okay all right so
okay now now budget no but not a big
deal now
i mean it's like you've done two tours
in vietnam walking down the street past
an alley is not a problem
you know that kind of thing right so
that that's where we are so uh uh
yeah then you just sit down and you're
gonna do
what you're looking for is a normal life
finally
to have a normal struggle to pay off
some debt and to live on the same page
together and that kind of thing and so
whatever lingering medical bills you
have whatever debts you have you're
going to begin to address those and the
two of you are going to sit down start
working the baby steps using a budget to
do that and working together
but you've learned to work together you
don't have a choice
it's true
um one
there's some great psychological
literature out there that suggests that
when people have the opportunity to peer
over the edge
whatever that looks like
that it
changes their
approach to through life
both
both of you in your marriage right and
so i would love
before you sit down and start doing the
math problems
i think it would be phenomenal to start
a weekly
dreaming session with your husband
answering one question
now that we've peered over the edge
who do we want to be
because most of us walk through life in
the illusion that we're going to make it
to 72 to 85 years old that's about the
average it's right and we'll be all
right and the reality is none of us know
and you got to lean over the edge you
had to sit in that room and have that
scary c-word conversation right you've
been there you've had chemo plugged in
you know
and now you can say
who do we want to be with the 10 minutes
or the 100 years we have left
right and then man budget becomes how do
we fulfill this cool thing because if we
owe some money when you get that knocked
out so that right if um we want to go
travel more i want you to quit your dumb
job because it's killing you faster than
my chemo is hurting me like let's do
that now like so you can make some of
those decisions based on who do we want
to be together what's the world we want
to create for ourselves and how can we
love and support those in our community
you see how radical of a different
approach that is
yeah you have the gift of perspective
it's one of the things that this is
going to give you is that gift
all this pain and all this and i don't
want that gift that's right i don't want
that i would you could keep your gift
but you've got it now right so the
question is what are you going to do
with it right
yeah you're a powerful
brave woman man i'm i'm glad it's an
honor to talk to you yeah um
pretty cool yeah very cool and if we can
help you in any way let us know but
basically you're gonna sit down to a
zero-based budget that aims the money
that you make towards your goals
but john's point is i think your goals
are going to be a lot more noble
a lot more um
you know your goals aren't going to be i
win a new car you know it could be it
could be if that's okay if it is but
it's
the shallowness that most people live in
i don't think you're going to struggle
with for a while
it may come back on you at some point
but right now
you've got the gift of perspective yeah
and uh and uh it was forced upon you you
didn't sign up for it and those those
bills just because they've got cancer on
them or doctors they are debts right and
they go online just with every other
debt and
and we're going to knock them out one at
a time yeah yeah best we
can so i've been asked john over the
years on the show uh many times
uh the first time it happened a guy
called me from atlanta pulled over to
the side of the road and sat on the side
of the road and talked to him he was on
his way home to tell his wife that he
was had been diagnosed with stage four
yikes and he said he said i got 90 days
that's what the doctor said
he's going home to his wife and he
called me on the radio from the side of
the road i'm like this
dude
there's a lot of other people but you
know but his whole point was he could
deal with it better if he had his ducks
in a row
on how to make sure she was taken care
of i got to get a will done i got to you
know pull the life insurance policies
out make sure i see what they what they
are i mean i've got i've got to lay out
a game plan here for her because i've
not got a lot of time to make sure she's
going to be okay
and that'll give me peace if i have done
that and so i you know when i understood
that i was okay i get it still kind of
weird that i get a phone call from the
side of the road like that but
uh
it's it's honoring and humbling uh but
but
from that day and all the different
calls similar that i've gotten over the
years obviously stephanie's
not in that situation she's got a
recovery going
uh
but anytime you get something like that
you know you what you want to do with
the baby steps and everything else is
just push full full stop
pause
pause
we're just going to pile up cash and
live in the moment
you know for the short couple of moments
we got it and our pile up cash and use
it to
clear this now once it's cleared in
september now she's going to go back to
doing a regular budget and a regular
rhythm on that which is a good thing to
do
desperately crave normal that's after
something like this but it's okay to
stop and pile up cash
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
so john um
a lot of stuff going on with questions
for
humans who would have thought man
who would have thought
i didn't
[Laughter]
john came to me with this idea and he
said we're going to make
cards like a deck of cards that helps
people start conversations
and so they can get off their cell
phones and actually talk to each other
and i said uh
that'll never work
and good god hundreds of thousands of
these things later was i wrong we're
doing all right with them all right we
can't keep them
i can't order them fast enough yeah
that's pretty cool man the most popular
thing
yeah
so yeah it's uh we've now we've got all
kinds of versions yes questions for
humans so that's the conversation
starters a little deck of cards and it's
got a question on it something like uh
what's your favorite movie or but
they're twisted they're not they're not
just like what's your favorite movie
it's
what make what movie
made you laugh so hard you peed your
pants and when when did you see it like
what was the story around that right so
we're trying to create communication
right right
um but yeah and after we put out the
first few decks then people said well
hey could you make one for my workplace
could you make one for my like girls
night out and i was like i haven't been
on a lot of girls nights but we're happy
to give it a shot we have some girls
that work here that are good on that
they can help us yeah brilliant women in
the room and figure out so anyway we're
working on them and uh putting them out
and it's it's been a blast man so now
we've added girls night out guys night
out dating conversation starters parents
and teens
yeah there's people that talk well
that one i can get okay workplace
edition
all of these are there so uh the created
the the we've created these questions
for human cards conversation starters
help you uh disconnect from your screens
and connect actual humans
and uh these are fun i mean i'm joking
around about it i'm actually telling the
truth i didn't think it would work but
uh but they've uh we we've had a lot of
fun with them around the office here in
different settings um
we started one in the uh uh one of the
leadership meetings the other day and
discovered that i've had more traffic
tickets than everyone else in the room
put together
so uh hey the other day we got a shot
we've got a few new decks coming that uh
i was editing and
uh i did them with my wife on the way to
our trip this past week
four hours in we're laughing telling
stories stuff i'd we've been we
celebrated our 20th anniversary i did
not know some of these stories about her
and vice versa so they were a lot
they're good man they're just good
they're fun so pick them up questions
from human questions for humans
conversation starter cards uh all these
different versions are there now at
ramseysolutions.com
and uh they're they're
flying off the shelves they're a big
deal and you're gonna love them they're
fabulous i mean i just love it when i'm
wrong so there you go and you get
tickets you get tickets what are the
tickets no do you get a lot of driving
tickets beating tickets oh oh of course
yeah you know that
yeah i didn't know that you were you
that's easy to predict that is yeah
exactly
fairly blinds.com is our question of the
day 100 satisfaction guarantee means
even if you mismeasure or you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping the new promos they run every
month and you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from mike in
texas mike writes my wife and i are in
baby step two and have been able to pay
about four thousand dollars of our debt
in the past three months
however we've hit some bumps along the
way my wife is the sweetest person i
know uh-oh anytime somebody starts a
sentence that way
i have the best wife but
my husband is so great but
my wife is the sweetest person i know
and she loves buying gifts for people
most recently she bought me a set of
power tools for three hundred dollars
and oh
that's so nice
i do enjoy woodworking i do not need or
want these tools i see that as a 300
chunk that could have been put towards
credit card debt because you're right is
there a way to politely decline this
gift from my wife and return it or
should i just be grateful for it and
move forward oh jesus whoa
you touch this one dave
um
everybody in this conversation is being
so nice that there's no communication
going on correct
you guys are the softest
you pussyfoot around everything none of
you make anything clear
ever exactly we're just in the it's like
it's like a saturday night live skit on
nice
you know you know what you're seeing yes
well she's nice but now i want to be
polite i see i want to be nice and this
is these people are not hillbillies i'm
just saying she buys gifts for other
people
to
that that's the way she buys self-esteem
for herself is she pictures herself as a
giving person
so much so that she will take care of
everybody else except for her own
household in order to put on errors that
she is this kind of person
he on the other hand is a wimp and a
coward
and
yes this is a hard conversation there's
no make no bones about it but if you and
your wife have sat down and said here is
a goal that we want to get out of debt
and you're cranking on it three months
four thousand bucks paying off a
thousand twelve hundred dollars a month
on this debt
there's nowhere that anyone in a
situation where the two of you are in
sync on baby step two there's not a
script where she goes and buys three
dollars for the two absolutely not i
don't know where that comes from she's
either trying to figure out if this um
either it's your birthday and you left
that out she's trying to figure out if
this boundary's gonna hold she she wants
to know if i do this for you then it's
gonna free her to go back to her away
her old ways
this in my house and if let's flip it
around if me and my wife did this and i
went and bought my wife's up for 300
bucks and i'm i'm doing that because
something like this has happened over
the course of my marriage
she got upset and she should have been
upset not because i bought our gift
because i've violated the covenant that
we made that here's a plan that we're
going to follow together and then i put
her as the recipient of this making it
her problem not ours anymore and that's
not it's not a cool it's just not cool
right it's manipulative it's
manipulative that's exactly right so the
thing is this um when you when she
walked in with a gift you should have
said no absolutely not we've been we're
in agreement and that would have caught
that would have been a part of a fight
that she had started you weren't causing
the fight at that moment you were we
were in agreement that we are getting
out of debt you buying me
uh 300 worth of stuff is not part of
that agreement absolutely not period yes
that's not that's not only not nice
it's in violation of you broke your word
to me that's right that's exactly right
you know and but you but this guy never
says anything like that he says oh
thanks i'm going to love these things
and then inside he's sick so i sneak him
back over to home depot and get the
credit right maybe i'll tell her later
yeah that no dude this is like when she
set the box down the counter you're like
what what do we do yeah
so tonight sit down and say hey we have
to have a hard conversation
um i'm grateful that you bought me these
things but you and i agreed that we were
going to do this and i'm not grateful
that you bought me these things and
that's right because you violated the
trust that we had put in each other yeah
and so it's more important to me that we
work together and that we keep word to
each other that to get out get rid of
this debt than it is whether i have some
power tools yes or whether you're
generous to me or whether i'm polite to
you and so let's put a list of things
that we want to buy and do with each for
each other and together in the future
and we're going to keep a running list
over the next three years while we get
out of debt let's keep it there or
something but this is just it's just a
violation man and um
yeah there's two
people who are struggling with their own
what they see in the mirror man they're
trying to make it work
you know what i did this too i i hadn't
even thought about it you said you've
done this but i mean i've been married
40 years so i've had lots of
opportunities to do crap wrong
so well i've done this a bunch dave
because sharon is a tight wad she does
not like to spend money yeah but her
nature isn't until she's ready and it's
something but i mean most the time
most the time her nature is she's a
saver and i'm a spender and i'm also a
uh one of my love languages is just
giving generosity and so
uh when we were too broke to do it
i would on her birthday or on an
anniversary buy her a dozen red roses
which is expensive
i mean i don't even know what that costs
now i still do it but it costs a lot
now it's crazy but uh even then it was
like you know whatever i spent a hundred
bucks let's say well a hundred million
dollars you're broke right hundred
dollars yeah and
you know where are those flowers in a
month exactly they're in the trash
you know and to her the uh the sentiment
did not keep up with the stupidity
that's right and so she was more
concerned about the stupidity than she
was the sentiment and it took her
a decade later from that to actually
accept flowers when we can afford them
and enjoy them
but now she's you know now she actually
can enjoy them so she got 40 roses on
her 40th
right which was a lot too but now i can
afford to throw them away in a month and
so now she's not it's not stupid anymore
but i back then i violated the same
thing this woman did that's right this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
me
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book own
your past change your future is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage thomas
and emily are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave hi dave good to have you
guys so where do you live uh we're from
clifton park new york okay which is near
uh albany okay cool cool good to have
you guys how much debt have you paid off
uh 41 000 in six months good for you and
your range of income during that time 70
000 to 125. good for you what do you
guys do for a living i'm an accountant i
am an indoor cycling instructor i work
on a farm and i run my own marketing
company whoa okay so how did you double
your income in six months uh i got a big
promotion at work and some bonuses along
the way uh and then she her business
kind of took off a couple websites that
she got
and all just kind of fell into place
good deal that's nice i love it when a
plan comes together
so what kind of debt was the 41 000 uh
so at that point it was i think i had
six thousand dollars left on my car and
then the rest of it was student loans
how long y'all been married uh six
months okay so you got married had the
plan to come home from the honeymoon and
attack this how in the world did you
make a weird decision like that and get
connected to this ramsey stuff so i
bought in a long time ago
i was sitting at work
and i was actually oddly enough trying
to figure out my budget to finance a bmw
and get all this different stuff that i
wanted to sign up for the engagement
ring
and uh i just was looking at the numbers
i'm like this doesn't work
so then i'm scrolling through financial
podcasts as us nerds do and came across
yours and i was like wow i've been wrong
the entire time
and then i kind of binged listened to
your podcast and then read the book went
through financial peace university and
here we are
okay and then you get engaged and so
emily you're like this guy uh
he's kind of over the top on this stuff
yeah he uh he bought into it a long time
before i did he would put it on whenever
we were driving in the car and i was
like you
yeah and he tried to guess what your
answers to people's questions would be
before you said it so i was like you're
just that's a good way to flex for her
how smart you are
probably i'll probably know what's
coming so what what pushed you over the
edge emily um well he proposed and i was
like well i'd rather get married to this
man than keep my credit card so i went
all in and and i cut it up and i was
like we're gonna be on the same page
we're just gonna do it it's a plan i'll
stick to it and here we are
you don't hear that very often
that's just like an act of character
yeah
that was pretty cool we need to have her
on your show on how to properly do that
like you just solved most of america's
issues right there i'd rather stay in
relationships so i just quit being
stupid and then i moved on my life like
that right there man heals
ah that's incredible man you married
well my brother good job
that was a mic drop right there that was
beautiful because i mean the number of
people that say
i want to do this but i also want to do
that i love him but i want my couch or i
really love her but i need my bmw like
i love her more so i'm just going to
just like being dumb
done yes so incredible man okay so you
you go through this plan you'll get
after it that's a lot of money you're
getting these bonuses you're getting new
websites and it's like i got a new
website it's like cool now we could pay
off more student loans exactly not that
didn't feel right right so walk us
through that journey
uh
i think
just because we had that mindset going
into it because we had started
separately like i started 40 months ago
and i was going through my own journey
separate and then she came in um so when
we actually had that influx of income
and actually we were saving up cash for
the wedding and uh our both our parents
helped us out tremendously with the
wedding so we were able to take all that
money that we stockpiled to pay
and they actually we put it on all the
debt so it really kind of rolled at all
who are you two
it's amazing there's free money dude to
go buy a new car with yeah yeah yeah
they all are incredible they're weird i
love it
very well done how's it feel to be free
uh awesome it's weird because every time
we you know every time i got paid from a
client or i got a paycheck i was so used
to watching that money go out of the
account right away and now it's just
it's kind of surreal watching it it
comes in it stays or i can spend it on
something that you know we budgeted for
and that i want to spend it on so it's
weird but it's good you have control of
your life now yeah that's beautiful well
done all right you're brand new married
you're unbelievably successful
very well done what do you uh tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
uh the budget
staying consistent i mean every month
your income is going to change like with
her business if a website comes in
sometimes they don't
so just when you get the extra money put
it on to whatever your goal is using the
snowball
and other than that i mean it's just
staying consistent and it helps to have
a team and you know we both kind of had
started beforehand and kind of plugged
along but once we were together and um
you know working at it and consistently
doing the budget um it just exploded
yeah how old are you guys uh we're 26.
she's much older than me though i'm a
week older than him
26 and you're debt free yeah yeah that's
pretty cool y'all won
but
more than anything they
know how to think together
they know how to dream together they
know how to execute how to execute
together they know how to get on the
same page
you know all of these tools that you
learn in this process are going to be
used throughout your life on other
things too so it's put your relationship
in a completely different place dude i
do relationships for a living and it's
very rare to hear somebody say i loved
him more than my stuff
hang on to that one that's she's good
well and it wasn't
you know and emily i put it on put words
in your mouth but you didn't do that
we're looking we have the benefit of
seeing your body language and everything
you were not saying i i you know i gave
up my brain i gave up my right you're
just saying i agreed with this i so i
chose yeah
i chose priorities yeah both it was it
was it was a mindful intellectual
decision an act of my will it was not a
i have to go along because i'm dumb it
wasn't that at all i mean there's a
bright
eyed very very uh sharp young lady
saying this very cool very cool y'all
very well done
not good at dating
playing podcast it's just like a move
but hey it worked it worked right yeah
it worked well done man yeah yeah do it
doing the right thing the wrong way
exactly
instead of smooth jazz we're going to
listen to
dave ramsey
hey we got a jazz opener whatever we do
have a chat
we do have a jazz opener well done man
congratulations we're proud of y'all
well done who was your biggest
cheerleaders uh both of our parents were
pretty big cheerleaders i mean during
this time her parents paid off their
mortgage oh
i actually got my mom to buy in a little
bit here because she saw what we were
doing and she's like hey that's pretty
cool how did you do that and i went
through her first budget with her and
kind of showed her everything so she'll
be on this stage i love it you're
changing you're changing legacy's the
other way right that's incredible yeah
change my family tree both directions
there we go good job you guys well we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure no question about it you
are on the way our latest number one
best seller for you
and a copy of total money makeover
coming up on its 20-year anniversary and
almost 9 million copies sold so i'll
give you a copy of that you can give it
away to somebody and get somebody
started it sounds like you're already
evangelizing this stuff a little bit
anyway and a financial peace university
one-year membership if you haven't been
through it go through it dr john deloney
is in the new videos with me and george
and rachel and they're the best best
teaching we've ever done it's really
really strong right now
so financial peace university all that
stuff you said you'd been through it so
maybe you give that to somebody as well
so whatever you want to do it's all
yours you can do what you want to with
it thomas and emily from new york and
the albany area 41 000 paid off in the
first six months of their marriage
making 70 to 125. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream ready three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
wow
yeah the
i can't get it out of my head the
opposite is a lady that called me one
time and she said uh her fiance wanted a
prenup to protect his classic car
and i said don't marry him absolutely
not this guy lives his car more than he
loves you this guy's not a keeper yep
so if you're my daughter i would prevent
you from marrying him if it meant his
death
stop it don't do it no and this is quite
the opposite it's the opposite the
opposite beautiful i'm not gonna find my
security in pieces of plastic i'm gonna
find like security in us and in
relationship in relationship let's do an
agreement yeah that is where we both
have a vote it's incredible wow powerful
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today bill's in san antonio hi
bill how are you
hey dave how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
man i'm so excited to talk to you um
so i'm 31 been married two years my wife
and i have about forty five thousand
dollars in student loan debt
uh
right now that's all we've got um
i work for my family in agriculture
farming and ranching
and
i make about 30 000 a year my wife makes
about 40. so
um
recently we've been hammering down on
the debt getting it paid off we got 25
000 down
got 45 to go
this house has come up it's owned by my
parents they want to sell it to us we
want to buy it we need it
um but you know we're trying to pay the
debt off
so i went to my folks i asked for a
raise i've been with him five years now
never had a pay raise in that time he
said why don't you just let us pay off
your your student loan debt and i said
man
i really i mean that's a wonderful
gesture and i appreciate it
but uh you know we've been working
really hard to pay this off and i feel
like if i take this money they're gonna
maybe there's gonna be some strings
attached and of course that's just based
on our relationship and that's a
different conversation
no it's not it's the same one it's the
exact same one bill
right okay there are no strings yes you
take the gift where there are strings
then we have to discuss the strings
how old are you man 31 31
how do they justify
i'm not gonna play it put it on them
i'll put on you
you're 31 years old making thirty
thousand dollars a year what are you
doing
i work for the family business no we
understand that i know that what do you
do physically why are you talking about
doing this you work too hard you're too
smart you your work ethic is too
striking two or three times that or four
yes i should i also have a business
degree from ole miss um
so
the reason why i do what i do is because
i love it um i'm not working for our
parents because i've got no other way
uh we raise cattle we raise sheep this
is my passion um i love my job and
i hope to someday have my own place and
this to me is the best way to get there
my own place to run my own business is
what i mean
how is thirty thousand dollars a year
getting you there
well it it's very it's slow
it's not it's not man
so um
uh what do they make
oh
gosh i don't know
um you have a business right yes you do
yeah you know
i would say over a million a year
so i'm gonna say this um and it's not
gonna be pretty but i'm getting
frustrated your parents are taking
advantage of you
this is strange it's not cool
it's disrespectful yeah
don't sound like my wife it's
disrespectful and what's happening is
it's pitting a relationship if they can
just cut you a 45 000 check to wipe it
it's a power play man
that's a move yeah and you smelled the
move i
i
dude i
i don't know man
i get wanting to be i'm from texas i get
one to have a ranch and run the cattle
those are some of my closest friends in
the world but you can't do that at 30
000 you're never going to earn the money
to buy your own ranch or you're playing
a 30-year long game with a couple of
power brokers that they may give you
their ranch someday it's not worth it
man
it's not worth it go get a job at
mcdonald's and make 30 grand at least
you can deliver pizzas at night and make
another 15 on top
you're killing yourself thirty thousand
bucks
well you don't you your day-to-day work
you enjoy doing the day-to-day work
um it's just but but i i honestly
believe you could manage a ranch for
somebody
uh as a you know with their business
degree and with your knowledge of the
actual
uh events that have to occur on the
ranch to win
i mean you know how to handle the cattle
you know how to purchase the cattle sell
the cattle and you know deal with the
issue you know how to do that so you
could work for someone else as a as a
manager and make 100 grand a year
couldn't you
maybe not 100 but i think i could double
my income but i'd have to move somewhere
yeah yeah yeah you would so my point is
if your parents hired someone to do what
you're doing they would have to pay them
more than they pay you
oh absolutely okay and that's where i
said you're getting taken advantage of
yep so the the rule in business the rule
and family business is this my kids work
for me okay
is they get paid what other people doing
the job that they are doing get paid
not more because they're family and not
less because they're family
and so rachel cruz is a ramsey
personality and rachel gets paid the
same percentages
on a book royalty that dr john deloney
gets paid as a ramsey personality
now she might sell more books or less
books and so she might make more or less
than he makes but not percentage she's
on the exact same comp schedule as ken
coleman as george camel as dr john
dolone and so that's rachel and so
rachel's not being mistreated by me uh
working here making less because she's
family uh and she's also not uh getting
paid more because she's here
working as family uh and she does stand
to inherit this place
okay yes sir so she so she doesn't have
to accept 30 000 a year instead she
makes what uh you know what these other
guys make doing this thing here that
we're doing so and same is true my son
daniel who's one of our senior vice
presidents and runs runs entre
leadership okay and uh so what what does
he make same thing as the other senior
vice presidents that are running
business units as a percentage of their
revenues and how they all get paid and
so you should be paid what someone else
that didn't didn't belong to your family
would be paid but not necessarily more
and so no i do not want the 45 000 and
yes i have to rethink whether i can stay
here at all
right well that's pretty much what i was
thinking dave
thank you yeah i'm sorry
and and and here's the thing if mom and
dad were making
no profit
and you were joining in on the family
business trying to get the thing turned
around and
putting your shoulder to the wheel
totally different that's a different
game
but they're they're probably making a
million dollars a year
well i mean i know what they make
because i know what their livestock is
worth hello
and uh
and so
you know and you're not you know you're
not coming in and asking for more
than market rate
but i'm no longer willing to accept less
than market rate
and of the promise of this inheritance
is not enough to keep me
absolutely not
because it's a bad arrangement in the
short term and that that arrangement
comes with strings yeah of all kinds
yeah and that's um
so it probably would be um
good for your mom and dad
relationship with you good for your
relationship with you good for your your
wife's relationship for you for you to
work on another ranch for a while
yeah you don't have to cut strings you
want to burn bridge you have to cut
strings but you like to burn bridges
yeah and just get you get your get your
marketplace savvy established
your value in the marketplace
established and then we can discuss
maybe in two or three years how to come
back
and under what circumstances you can
come back
and it's going to be market rate then
with a plan towards succession in the
business that's laid out
yeah we all recommend that i
have this conversation again with them
um now that i've listened to you and i'm
probably a little bit more confident
um i mean obviously you guys don't know
them from adam but yeah i mean is it
words another word yeah it doesn't hurt
yeah it doesn't hurt anything i think
you tell them i'm going to start i'm
going to reach out to seek this this
amount of money this is what my time and
my experience and my knowledge and my
value is
and i want to put you all on notice i'm
going to be looking for this type of
work across the across the southeast
region right southwestern right
southwestern yeah wherever you happen to
be yeah but the uh yeah i i um but i i
you know
it would be if you want to stay there
and they suddenly want to clean this
thing up then that'd be okay
but
i i'll be honest with you i i think if
they were going to do that they would
already done it right
and my experience has been kids who grow
up in this type of relationship um
undervalue themselves because they've
been undervalued and your wife you
mentioned it she sees it she knows what
her husband's work and she's not just
mad at your mama no i want you to see
what you're worth my brother yeah
[Music]
that's a long answer too no don't take
the money
yeah
so fun
wow interesting that puts this hour the
ramsay show in the books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book own your past change
your future and host to the doctor john
delaney show is my co-host today open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five brittany's in chicago
hi brittany how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so my question is actually about
anxiety
um i just finished baby step three and
i'm scared to move on to baby sets four
through six specifically baby step six
um i'm a single mother of two and i'm
just scared that i don't have enough
saved and i'm worried about putting
money where i can't usually access it
um
so i'm just wondering if you have any
advice i'm getting past this fear
have you had
seasons of insecurity in your past
yes you're a single mom yeah how long
have you been a single mom
i was trying to be facetious i didn't i
asked that too seriously yes you've been
through it before right yes did you grow
up struggling
absolutely i'm
the daughter of a single mother as well
okay so think of it this way you ever
been going somewhere on your gps on your
phone and somebody puts a pin in it for
you
to tell you where to go
your body
has put a pin in
not having enough
and it is constantly trying to solve for
not having enough and it will continue
to move the finish line on you
that's why it's real important when
we're doing the baby steps is that we
don't go by feelings we go by the data
okay
you got six months what do you do for a
living
i work for a non-profit okay uh how long
have you been there yeah
there specifically not too long about a
month
if you lost that job how quick could you
find a job
um
exactly 10 minutes 15 minutes right so
here's the deal the data tells us
that within six months you'd be fine
within one month you'd be fine
your bills would be covered you got six
months to sit on
right and so we're gonna lean into and
here's the thing about anxiety is it we
want to run from it and then it spins
faster on us so here's what i want you
to do i want you to turn and face it and
walk right in the middle of it
i want you to lean into the next step on
this plan
baby you you're going to four five and
six here
lean into it
go right towards it because here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna teach our
body that at one time there wasn't
enough
now there is
and when your body realizes you're
driving you're in control you're running
the show
and you've got the
you're not just flexing you're not just
like yeah yeah that's you you're not
just some [ __ ] college kid right
you got six months in the bank you're
got a great job you've got consistency
you've got fill in the blank
it goes ah okay cool she's driving we
don't have to sound the alarms anymore
now we're good
see what i'm saying and it's gonna take
a process you're gonna have to learn
this over a couple of years
i'm good
right you're gonna ask yourself when
that alarm kicks off
uh what are you trying to teach me uh
we're good we got this one and just
gonna go okay good
so brittany um
there's a guy named mike todd that has a
wonderful quote he says um
i've never
been poor i've only been broke poor is a
state of mind
and when you get the tapes running in
your head
either from your childhood or from
this time you've had starving to death
as a single mom struggling
or both when the tapes run in your head
uh you can get stuck in a mental cycle
that says there's never going to be
enough i'm always going to be short and
it's kind of this dark cloud
hanging over you and and so it's kind of
a thing
it's a mental exercise to
uh to change
your uh perspective from one of oh god
what's going to happen next to oh god
what's going to happen next
you know what good thing you know it's
an abundance thing but that's just a
decision to do that and to start
practicing it is what john's talking
about there
and um
then that will set you free so
uh you've probably had the experience i
know i have where
i'm all spun up about something and then
i actually get to looking at the detail
and i go ah
don't sweat the small stuff and by the
way this is small stuff
and so uh and then you because you you
kind of pan back
or you dive in one of the two and you
see that it's gonna be okay and there's
this kind of
thing happens like um
you know the time your kid got lost in
the grocery store
it's happened to every one of us right
right and for a minute
they're they're already trafficked and
they're in the middle east somewhere
in your mind right
and your brain goes completely bonkers
until they turn the corner holding the
stock clerk's hand
with this stupid grin on their face and
you go oh okay you were just stuck in
the green beans i got it holding the
lollipop yeah yeah and um yeah now we're
all okay right but there was a moment
there that you were spun up way beyond
the actual situation
fearing the worst
and that's human nature and that's
exactly what you're doing with this does
that make you sense
yes absolutely so here's the hard hard
thing about anxiety
it's a choice moving forward
and what do i mean by choice that means
i'm going to work on getting some sleep
at night so that my body is at its tip
top shape i'm gonna eat right i'm gonna
move my body i'm gonna have
relationships with people i'm gonna do
the things they're gonna give my body's
alarm systems they're gonna be all tuned
up
and i'm going to choose to like dave
said my identity is no longer i'm poor
my identity is i'm enough
and i have busted it
to get a six-month emergency fund now
i'm gonna start saving for house now
we're gonna start planning for college
and i'm gonna start doing retirement i'm
gonna start set planting seeds baby
steps from millionaire in the making
now we're off to the races because
that's who i am so we're gonna create an
identity and we're gonna work backwards
from there you got it
you are incredible you know what the
beautiful part about this whole thing is
uh
you actually could
you recognized it was there
and my dad used to say that to me when i
was growing up he said he would say
okay uh recognizing a problem is ninety
percent of solving it
and the rest of it's just execution now
you gotta go do it yeah yeah yeah he
also said that about work he said i
identified that the basement need to be
cleaned so i've done most of the work
now you go do the work
that's right
i think that was a trick of course
i worked really hard identifying it and
uh
thinking of it's half the work
i've already done half the work so you
go do the other half yes
so um yeah that that's uh but that's the
thing we we all have this stuff
and that's why we always say around her
personal finances 80 behavior
because if i can get this guy in the
mirror this gal in your mirror to
believe again
and behave in such a way that we're
going to win
then guess what we end up doing winning
there's a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's tied into every bit of this
and it's a poverty mentality a scarcity
mentality versus a wealthy person's
mentality an abundance mentality and it
is a series of thoughts and training
that causes your brain and your body to
do these things
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well right now you're hearing a lot of
talking heads about fear in the real
estate market
and uh that the housing market's gonna
crash
2008 it's all coming down the robot the
robots the robots are taking over
uh but you're not hearing the truth as a
matter of fact you can't make decisions
john talks about this all the time
uh when you're in the middle of fear
facts are your friends you need facts
and here they are in 2008 there was a
huge
supply of homes as a matter of fact 3.8
million homes on the market in 2008.
you know how many houses are on the
market today eighteen thousand
one fourth the inventory now
one fourth
oh and new housing starts in two
thousand six seven two million
today 1.3 million
so we don't have new housing
supply we don't have used housing supply
and uh
guess what we got twice as many buyers
twice the demand
for less than half the supply we're not
going to have a housing crash now prices
are going are you know they're going to
slow down this ridiculous increase is
going to stop and maybe the auction that
we've been having where every house goes
on the market in 85 offers coming is on
the is not going to happen but it's
going to slow down we are heading into a
light recession or
something very close to one or something
like that where we're actually in the
third quarter now so we'll just know
whether q2 was a recession not soon but
um if it is a recession isn't going to
be much of one i thought it was going to
be now they're saying maybe it didn't so
we'll see when the numbers come out in a
week or so but bottom line is the
market's slowed down but it's not
crashing
you do need if you're a buyer a good
real estate agent in your corner that
knows what they're doing
and you do need a good real estate agent
in your corner knows what they're doing
if you're a seller because they're going
to explain to you your house is not
going to sell in one minute
or 17 minutes
it's going to sell in 90 to 120 days
which is when houses have sold most of
history
just only this recent weirdness that
we've been in could you put your house
up for sale and get much more than it
was worth for it
and get multiple offers for that you and
i have a friend that
what they wait 36 hours and they freaked
out and dropped the price way down for
him to buy a house crazy what are you
doing crazy after 36 hours he went
hadn't sold and sold got the price
dropped
nice so you sellers have to have
somebody talk you out of your tree right
yes because you're up in the tree
chasing a cat so you need a good real
estate agent in your corner
ramsey trusted agents are elps endorsed
local providers they're incredible
they're high octane high protein agents
with proven track records they can help
you navigate this market
and you should have somebody like that
in your corner so go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent get a good
high-end real estate high quality real
estate agent in your corner to buy or
sell right now and it is a good time
right now to do either
you know a year ago it was a bad time to
be a buyer
but now is actually a pretty good time
to be a buyer a year ago it was a great
time to be a seller
now it's just a good time to be a seller
so a good time to be a buyer good time
to be a seller it's a weird market
because you usually have to say one of
the others kind of got the advantage
right now this fairly even playing field
in most markets now some of these
markets are still heated up
they're still white hot and some of
these markets are slowing down
dramatically because they've got other
stuff other than just national things
going on
um some of the folks around the oil
fields in texas um
they ain't working yep
it's hurting those markets yeah hurting
those markets that but that's a local
economic thing that they're gonna do
that's not affecting that's not
affecting kansas city yeah but they take
those local stories and they dump them
in the national news and put big red
ticker tape around them and say breaking
news and you think your market's falling
apart no and it's not no and i
i think dave is so important whether
it's real estate whether it's um i've
been working with dr norton lane norton
is a brilliant guy um you met him there
in orlando gave me a shirt that said
data is greater than feelings he's
working with me on some weightlifting
stuff and some nutrition stuff
i wanted to feel like i this and he's
like dude you gotta just follow the
program just follow this the data and
stop yeah but i feel like just fall and
dude it's working and then the same
conversation we have people about their
money i feel like it just follow the
program same with rental hot running a
house whenever you get emotional about
something
slow down and follow the data follow the
facts man and if you don't have them get
somebody who's wise in your corner and
you always going to make better
decisions when you're looking at real
numbers it's just amazing how we don't
do that matt is in new york city hey
matt welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call how
are you better than we deserve brother
what's up
uh nothing much so i'm just trying to
figure out um i have about five thousand
uh dollars to my name right now good for
you um i do
that's in a checking account
i currently do not have a savings
account but i'm looking to
take
portions of my salary and my paycheck
from my job
you know and put that away to start
saving up money because i'm looking to
get engaged in about two years um and
then eventually moved and get married
and move down south to florida um so i'm
looking to have you found her yet
yes yes i have why would it take two
years what are you doing man
two years
i'm only uh i'm only 22. but um you know
just looking at it just looking to stay
here have you got a job
yes i do right right now how old is she
investigator
she's 22 as well
you're a private investigator
yes sir so what what where was the rule
that said you can't get married before
24. i'm from tennessee
yeah i mean that's all uh
you know i was i was i was crazy i was
raised with what you know with my uh my
father my parents i was raised to always
ask um
you know ask her ask your father for her
hand in marriage and whatnot that don't
take two years
i know well uh
her parents her parents are a bit strict
um
she's 22. who cares what her parents
they don't get a vote dude
right exactly
that's that's exactly that's exactly
what i said to her
um so i think you go talk to her dad and
and uh go and get married that's my
opinion but what am i
i don't think you need to wait two years
it's just unhealthy i think you need to
uh you know
if this is the if this is the right
thing let's go ahead and go forward if
it's not then get off the ladder but um
you know if if she is not mature enough
at 22 years old to live on her own as a
woman then you got other issues
right
but if you and if you aren't
but that that's a different thing but
that's uh
no there's no rule anyway so all of that
to say
uh five thousand dollars to get engaged
is great i think that's a good start we
got a little bit of a beginner emergency
fund you have any debt you need to clean
up
uh no debt at all does she
no no wow you guys are you are in great
shape then so she has a job you have a
job you have five thousand dollars
correct okay
and so uh i you know is there something
in your life that makes you
a bad guy
that her dad should say no you can't
marry her
oh not not at all i mean her her dad her
dad treats me like i'm his own son
you know both both of her parents who
are both her mom and her dad do you wear
sleeves most of the time or do you cut
them off
no i wear sleeves most of the time all
right that's that's good
i'm just saying if somebody if a guy
comes to my house to to marry my
daughter josephine and he's going to cut
all the cuts sleeves off a shirt cut
straight leaves off a shirt
that's why i'm asking him is he one of
those guys i didn't even know what
you're talking about he got it he knew
oh my god do you have a mustache
absolutely not
uh
slightly slightly better the problem
dude you gotta shave
i'm tell i'm just kidding i'm messing
with you i mess with you
okay so if the rolls were reversed
and this was your daughter
and this guy that looks and acts like
you came and asked for her hand would
you grant it
i mean
i don't know i don't know why why would
i feel like no why wouldn't you if you
were her dad
and some guy comes it's your daughter
someday this role is going to happen to
you
right
and and he comes is he gonna would you
be happy
to put her hand in this young man's hand
i would but there would be there would
be some um
you know i mean i feel like her i feel
like her dad wants me to have a
uh
have a steady you know have a steady job
where i'm making or i'm making a
i don't know a decent amount of money
because right now with with the private
investigation work i'm making about
18.50 an hour so go get a better job
yeah
do both
do that
and then go get the girl don't wait two
years
that's a couple old men talking right
there make it happen matt this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
scott is with us scott is in
winston-salem north carolina with hope
city church
the church is debt-free we here scott
tell us about this
hey hey dave thanks for having us man
this is awesome we're all excited
but yeah the church is debt-free we saw
some light at the end of the tunnel and
we cast some vision for it we pushed it
we got everybody on board and like the
church god
did some amazing things so yeah we're
debt free to be generous as we possibly
can be
yeah it's a whole lot easier to help
people in the community when you don't
have payments to the bank
that's awesome man congratulations so
you are you the pastor scott
yeah yeah lead pastor started the church
in 2011. wonderful very cool
okay so tell us what happened here how
much debt was there and where did the
vision come from to clear it and how did
you all do it
so in 2016 we purchased some land we
built a four million dollar facility and
we it's a beautiful place we're here
about two years ago we saw this thing
getting down to right at two million
dollars
you know coping is happening around
there but we're like you know what i
think right now is the time to get out
of debt
we cast a vision to our staff our staff
was unified in it our leadership team
was unified in it and the church jumped
on board and as soon as we started
casting a vision to get out of debt
to pay off his last two million dollars
dave i can't tell you like
we had someone give us a million dollar
gift whoa we have yeah we had another
person give us a 225 000 gift
we had some excess land that we were
ever probably going to use we sold that
off for another 205 000 so this thing
really started to snowball
and then like i you know casting the
vision to people who don't even come to
our church i had friends who i play some
golf with they they would just give us
you know a gift here and there and it
all just added up
until
right after easter this year
that was our final push and we only had
to pay off like 314 thousand dollars and
when you're talking 4 million to 314 000
that seems like just
really nothing and we wiped out that
remaining 314 000
and now we're debt free so it's been an
amazing ride over the last year or so
wow well the fear
around covid for churches like for
businesses and for individuals was that
the re that the income was going to shut
down
and a lot of churches that we've worked
with have told us that their income
actually went up
during covey did you all experience that
yeah we did dave you know we had a
couple of options that we could have
gone
into sort of a recluse mode or we could
have taken a couple other options
that
really would have taken the focus off of
who our provider is and we just we
didn't go that direction we said
generosity is one of our core values
it doesn't matter what kind of season
we're in we've got to continue to be
generous and god just provided and he's
been faithful and you know it's
something you've heard all over it's
nothing new but you cannot out give god
and and we keep trying to do it but we
keep failing at it and so we're just
going to continue to roll in that
direction amen brother amen that is
wonderful
well as as you know the leader and
founder of that organization you
probably experienced the same thing i
did before giving went up
there we were in the middle of this
quarantine in the shutdown and uh you
know
you had to look at this and go
man if we didn't have this debt we'd be
in a whole different place
and so this is my wake-up call that had
to be part of this formula
yeah it definitely was really you know
not knowing what tomorrow holds
you know not having to pay the bank our
our note was roughly 14 000 a month and
we're not a mega church you know we we
have about 600 people that worship with
us on a sunday morning so
you know one wrong move one wrong
statement uh it just could go south
quick so we were just like let's get
this thing out of debt let's put this 14
000
into the community to continue to truly
make an impact in this community for the
lord and that's just what we're doing
that's powerful yeah that's 14 000 worth
of help you can be to people around
there that was just going to a stupid
bank that's so wonderful i'm so proud of
y'all well done pastor
very well
scott i wrote this down the antidote to
fear
is generosity
what if when we all got scared and
nervous and anxious we immediately
didn't run to the mirror and say what
about me what about me but we looked
around and said who could we serve right
now i wonder what our culture would look
like if we were generosity focused when
we got scared instead of inward focus
good for you man what an example amen
thank you well i i predict a spike in
growth at your church
following this uh i think your your
people are going to be bolder more
courageous you probably will be in the
pulpit uh yeah not that you were wimpy
before yeah
you can do all the sermons now that
you've been wanting to say
yeah but uh you know it's uh it does
change it changes a business person the
way we run our business we're more bold
uh we've got a little more flex that we
didn't have when we don't have the bank
hanging around our neck and it does it
affects the pulpit the other thing that
you'll end up doing is you'll end up
infecting these families
with this debt-free disease and they
will go on and prosper
inside of your congregation
and uh
you can't help but do it you can't stop
it from happening because of what you've
done i'm so proud of y'all this is such
a wonderful statement and what you've
done congratulations very well done
uh any advice for pastors out there of
thousand member and under congregations
that are sitting on uh seven figures of
debt they're sitting on a couple million
dollars in debt any advice for them
yeah i think you really have to go first
you have to be the leader you know
you've heard some of the gurus out there
in leadership talks they say good
leaders go first great leaders come back
and take others with them i think this
is huge for us because we can tell
people now hey we've done this if we've
done it we will show you how you and
your family can do it as well and so
it's just it really gives us cred you
know credibility that we we want this
for you because there is
a feeling you know i know it's not all
about feelings but there is a freedom
that you feel in your heart your soul
and your mind when you drive into this
place every day and knowing that it's
paid off you know with your homeowners
you say the grass is always greener now
that is paid off
i remember the first day monday morning
coming back to this
police days after we had paid it off man
the parking lot was cleaner the the
building was brighter i mean i'm not
kidding it was free
and in every family
that's not only here at our church
pastors whatever i want them to be able
to experience that because we weren't
made to be just held down in bondage
yeah beautiful well done pastor so proud
of you guys so uh i understand we got a
video of you a whole of your whole
church congregation doing a debt-free
scream right
yes sir yes sir all right well we will
cue that up and again as we queue that
up congratulations our love to you and
all of your team and our congratulations
to you we're very very proud of you all
right fire that up guys in the booth
okay ready three
two
one we're dead free
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
a church-wide debt-free scream i love it
very well done
yeah i love the idea of the bride of
christ not being in chains for real man
and i love the idea of that fourteen
thousand dollars a month
now they're gonna look at that and say
who are we gonna bless this week yeah
who are getting blessed this week single
mom needs some help some hungry kid
needs help the church can be about the
business of the church right which is
minister loving people and you know what
i'm sorry boys and girls but that takes
money it does it takes money and that's
14 000 a month and not going to some
stupid bank and if you're a stupid bank
i'm sorry you're just a stupid bank if
you're a church
get out of that man that's so cool get
out of debt for your people that is so
beautiful wow
that's incredible frees you up to be
able to do and be who you is supposed to
be i love it well done pastor this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today john 10 10 the thief
comes only to steal kill and destroy i
came that they may have life and have it
abundantly
diane ackerman said i don't want to get
to the end of my life and find that i
lived just the length of it
i want to have lived the width of it as
well oh that's good
i like that
very good good stuff joe's with us joe
is in chicago hi joe how are you
hi i'm doing well and today talking to
you is a good one
thank you sir how can we help
i've got a question about what to do
with a gift that's currently sitting in
a mutual fund so i'm 19 years old and i
have one year of college under my belt
and due to my generous parents a good
scholarship and a relatively cheap
school i'm casual in college with my
on-campus job and then saving what i
make in the summer good for you but uh
what are your studies
i am taking a major in business
information systems and it's a master's
program as well for public accountancy
wow good for you
good good good field how can we help
so when i was born my kind and generous
great aunt set aside some money for me
which uh peaked at about three thousand
dollars but has since fallen to around
twenty five hundred
now uh if i was given this in cash i
wouldn't invest it because right now the
goal is just to pile up cash until i
graduate
but uh when i talked to her about
pulling it out she uh voiced some
concerns about uh about pulling it
because the market's down
and i was trying to balance uh
pulling it out which i think would be a
good idea why do you think that would be
a good idea you don't need the money
today
no i don't but if i had the money in
cash i wouldn't invest it
that's a fair uh
assumption
i don't disagree with that
if you call me and had the money in cash
in your situation i would have you pile
it up just to make sure you graduate
sounds like you've got our answers on
the show dialed in
i'm sorry it sounds like you listen to
the show and you know how we answer
questions
yeah i listen every day okay all your
shows so i mean because you're you're
you're you know i'm hearing my words
so uh uh thank you for that i appreciate
that i'm honored by that so you're right
thank you if you called me at 19 years
old and you had five thousand dollars or
three thousand dollars cash sitting in
the middle of the table and said i want
to put it in mutual funds i would say
don't
because i want you to graduate debt-free
first and you've got it mapped out where
you can without using this money
probably but just in case i would use it
as an insurance policy okay
um and so you're you're right i would do
that and um that's what you're saying
uh
in this case the money is not in the
middle of your kitchen table it is
already in the market and your ant is
actually right it's the wrong time to
pull it
um because you know with the market uh
it went down you know we were
technically in a bear market probably
not technically now but whatever
it's down a bunch either way since the
first of the year
and i don't think it's going to stay
down throughout your college career and
you don't need the money today so i
probably would ride this thing back up
i kind of go agree with your aunt here
which i usually wouldn't do i admit i
admit that i admit that okay i usually
wouldn't do it or if you told me that i
have to have this money to keep from
borrowing money to go to school
i would tell you cash it out no that's
been happening that would have been a
heartbeat i mean i'm sorry the market's
down you just need the money but uh but
right now you have the luxury
of not having to cash it out while the
market's down and that's your aunt's
point and i tend to agree with her
all right well thank you yeah so but i i
man i really appreciate that you had
thought through what we were going to
say yeah yeah but my my understanding is
when the market's down you cash out
you're solidifying the loss and so if it
goes down at some point
you either gotta
in general in general you never sell or
write it down right because you what we
call lock in your losses right uh
solidifies the word you've been you're
locking them in you're promising
yourself you're gonna lose you're not
just haven't just lost on paper now you
really lost right would you cash it in
while it's down so if you don't have to
take it out while it's down it's the
exact wrong time to take it out
um
but if you have to you just have to i
mean it's just part of it it just sucks
but uh but yeah i
you know i'm gonna ride it back up and
and let it get back up in that 3000
range then i might cash it out yeah and
just as a matter of safety and you might
i might miss out on some upward returns
that seems a little backward to say that
but
i'm sure that's consistent but either
way it's just what i would do and it's
not a lot of money
it's not going to make or break your
college career probably sound like 30
000 or 100 000 that's gone down to 75
000. we're talking
three grand that's gone down to 2 500.
that's true we're playing with
we're playing with house money too well
so let me let me i have a problem with
that so if i
worked and earned 3 000 bucks and put it
in there and it drops 500 bucks
i feel a psychological angst that is
different than if somebody gave me 3 000
bucks and it's dropped down because
that's house money but i don't know that
that's the right way to look at it three
thousand bucks is three thousand bucks
is three thousand bucks where no matter
where it came from that's right that's
that's my problem i got to get over here
and um the only thing you don't want to
do is dishonor the giver here correct
but it didn't sound like the ant was
being controlling it sounded like she's
just advised yeah that's advising and
saying
i didn't sense that from him anyway so
interesting good discussion
rich is with us rich is in phoenix hi
rich how are you
hi dave and john honored to talk to both
of you you too how can we help
so a quick snapshot of my situation um
i'm 45 years old and my wife and i have
been married for about two years
just over two years and
we became debt free last year
both had a little bit of car debt coming
into our marriage and we paid it off
really quickly
and i've got about 111 000 sitting in a
retirement account and we have our
emergency fund saved up so i'm just kind
of at that point where
if you were in my shoes what would you
do dave
uh you mean in the baby steps or what
yeah i i'm i'm debating on jumping right
into step four uh with 15 percent uh but
my wife and i were talking about it that
we don't want to skip over 3b and i just
don't know if there's like so you're
wanting to buy a house
yes sir okay
and uh well i mean what if you took
two years to work on baby step 3b and
did not put money into retirement
okay and you built up a good down
payment what does that do to you versus
putting 15 percent during that two years
into there how much of it how much will
that affect your
you know your down payment what's your
household income
uh just over a hundred thousand okay so
it's a
fifteen thousand a year swing thirty
thousand dollar swing on how much is in
your down payment
if you put fifteen percent away
you're going to have thirty thousand
less in two years correct
correct in in your down payment fund
that's correct yeah so um
you know can we get to a good down
payment doing that and would we rather
have a smaller down payment and do that
or would we rather three b's kind of
optional how much you lean into baby
step four while you're doing it we let
you decide that uh we suggest you don't
go zero into baby step four for more
than three years
while you're doing your down payment
saving
but uh if you want to do partial if one
of you has got a match sometimes people
do that
uh like whenever you've got a four
percent match so you put in four percent
to get the match
and we do a partial baby step four while
we're working on our down payment in 3b
and then as soon as the down payment's
done boom we're at 456 which is 15 kids
college and house so once you've done
that but while we're working on this
down payment during this three year
state of flux it can be zero
to 15 percent going into for into baby
step four
your choice there's not a wrong answer
it's how do you guys wanna work this
stuff how much do you wanna lean into it
but i would you're asking what i would
do i would lean toward
um
i i i would lean in in the direction of
buying a house
because i don't think houses are going
to go down in value and i've spent the
last several weeks being criticized for
saying that but
um
you know
such is life um some of my uh
predictions come out crystal clear
correct and some of them i was just
wrong so this one i'm not wrong on
though um so
there's way too much data on this one
this is not just a dave gut feeling
there's just data
so anyway yeah i'm buying a house that's
what i would do if you're in this market
i'm gonna save up as fast as i can and
i'm gonna buy a house because i think
they're going to go up next year four or
five percent and next year four five
percent and the next year four or five
percent
and that means fifteen percent twenty
percent up
three four years from now yeah so i
would buy you know as quick as you can
get the down payment save and do your
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
good job dr john deloney austin ben zach
andrew james and kelly in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you